one thing that about about uh
being in an elevator that gets my
girdle i mean it just boils my damn
beef uh boils my beef
is when somebody gets in with a little
child
and they're like okay okay tanner press
the button
and tanner's standing there he's got all
10 fingers up his nose
you know he's just straight bug hunting
he don't give a damn
and they're like all right tanner press
the button
and tanner's like
then he beats his damn little booger
hunters up against the
alt like you know up against all the
buttons
and it reminds me actually i got to tell
you this one this one story uh
i'm in an elevator i'm going back to
elevators and i'm in the elevator i get
in and this couple gets in at the same
time
and they have a little child man and
this child probably been alive maybe i'm
guessing
probably 170 days you know he still
smelled a little gamey
still a little gamey in the air
and uh you know like if an animal came
up i bet he would pick that little baby
up by the back of the neck you know what
i'm saying he's still a little
fresh out that mom body
so we're in there we get in and
i i feel like the mom had maybe been
drinking and she said to the husband she
said oh honey maybe dunstan will want to
press the button
and first of all you can't name a baby
dunstan
you can't name a baby dunstan man i
think dunstan is a as a baseball bat
you can't name a baby dunstan
think about a baby named dunstan dude
yeah you can't so
i'm looking i'm like dunstan and i'm
looking at the baby and i'm thinking
well sure
surely she doesn't mean the baby the
baby is five months old
that baby couldn't dunstan will have he
he you know he can't
move his arms he don't he's like a
scarecrow with no scare in him
he can't do nothing you know
um i mean a snake could eat him
you know he has no dumpster don't have
any capabilities
so she's like dumb honey honey maybe
dunstan would like to push the buttons
and i'm standing there like we gotta get
going
you know we've been about 18 seconds
that's a long time
to start it for an elevator to start in
modern day
so then the husband he has he has this
look on his face like what like i don't
but then you can tell who wears the
pants and the family the lady
and i don't know if she like wanted to
show off for me or what she's thinking
but
next thing you know the guy like puts
you know dunstan by the
buttons and he don't do nothing i knew
he wasn't going to do nothing
and i'm thinking man i wish i had a law
degree somebody needs to be here
on behalf of dustin
somebody could have done some best
interests man
and then they take dusty man and the dad
like puts him by the thing and he's not
pressing him
because he can't press him because he
can't do
anything the only thing he's pressing or
even thinking about pressing is just
pressing a tit into his face you know
he's that milk hound baby he's that
[ __ ] leche weasel daddy
so now he like takes the baby
and like pushes the baby against the
buttons
like the side of the bait like the
shoulder and the ear and the
in in the head he like pushes like three
buttons
with little dust and is pushing him up
against the buttons man
and i pushed my own man he's like what
floor you want to go to i was like
i'll give dunstan's already done enough
man we're going to four [ __ ] floors
that none of us are on
i'll go where i need to go i'll handle
my own [ __ ] good evening good afternoon
and other times thanks for watching that
video you just saw
i mean it was okay but the next video
you can watch
could be way better what if you watch a
video right now that changes
your life well you could watch this one
or watch this one
watch this one watch this one watch this
one